oh wait mike good to see you listen it
it is awesome to talk to you you know
how much i love your work obviously but
i've not seen your home and i'm just
checking out that backdrop awesome uh
yeah i got to tell you as as a fan of
your work and what you did with the
character i really would have liked to
have seen you fighting this guy yeah
right totally
yeah
i'm just i'm just throwing that out
there um so i got a few fun questions
for you we'll find out if you like them
um
uh have you finally seen the reader
yes
good question
just curious um if logan were to be in
the reminiscence machine what would he
be dreaming about
oh
what would he be i think he'd be way too
frightened to go in there
but there might be a little gene in
there
there may be a few gene moments
and you know i always wondered why there
wasn't more storm moments
so let's just say he's going to go there
too
uh i am curious listen you've had an
amazing career thus far but i'm sure
that there's been projects along the way
that maybe you went after and didn't get
is there one that still stings that
you're like oh my god i really wanted
that role
chicago
so
yeah that it was sort of a
from memory
timing
and also i just remember going
i'm too
young like i think i was 31 it was
straight after x-men
and i'd obviously done some musicals so
they were interested in before and i was
like i said billy flynn has a line i've
seen it i've seen it listen kid i've
seen it all i've seen it all kids
something like that and i thought this
is with renee and i said i think they're
the same age as me that's gonna be a
weird line
why i didn't just think put on some
makeup i don't know like i remember
watching that movie steve with my palms
were just sweating the whole literally
from the beginning i'm like
oh this was a bad this is a bad mistake
jumping into why i get to talk to you i
love learning about the behind the
scenes of the making of movies um what
do you think would surprise people to
learn about the making of this film and
working with lisa
well lisa and her team discovered a new
way of filming to make the holograms
real
so
we were
all those reminiscences that you see
from the machine
was real
in camera not a special effect
and it was
i still can't even explain it to you the
math the physics of it it it actually
was really really difficult to do and it
took loads of people that had people
working on it for a year but i think
most people are gonna see that
unfortunately just assume it's a really
cool special effect
but hopefully you can get the word out
and say that was real and it was a
pioneering part of it i think also you
might think about releasing like a
behind the scenes clip showing uh
you know you guys have plenty a few
weeks still to let people know that this
is you know real that's a great idea
because it was it had never been sold
before and never been done before so and
then sometimes it takes first-time
filmmakers to go now let's why can't we
do it that way you know and so there
were some moments i think in the first
few weeks of shooting where she was like
uh this is taking us a long time to set
up and you know
um but i think it's totally worth it
what are you gonna do later this year do
you know your schedule yet yeah i'm
doing the music now so on broadway
so october 25 first day of rehearsals
i'm about to go and shoot the sun now
with florian zeller
the follow-up movie to the father
and then i go
to broadway man so i'll be back seeing
broadway reopen cannot wait listen sir
congratulations on everything you know
how much i love you
have a fantastic afternoon great to see
you steve